I'll race with these things hi my name
is Wyatt Knox you may recognize Wyatt
from my previous wired video I'm the
special projects director here at the
team O'Neil Riley school and today I'm
breaking down clips for movies and
television about driving roll clip
drifting faster the Furious Tokyo Drift
[Music]
so the scenario that we've got in this
movie is that they're racing up through
a parking garage to get to the top level
any racing driver would tell you that
this is sort of nonsense if you're
trying to get up as quickly as possible
you wouldn't be drifting much but it is
a lot more fun and it's certainly more
spectacular to watch it a movie and you
can give me some poner sometime so
there's a couple of different ways you
can initiate a drift depending on how
much speed you have you can come into
the corner using the handbrake to create
some rotation finish that off by you
know using more throttle than you would
need on that surface to spin the rear
tires another great way to do it so what
we just saw here which is the clutch
kick which is while you're on the
throttle if you just clutch in the
engines gonna rev up and then when you
clutch out again it's gonna shock load
those rear tires into spinning and then
creating oversteer around the corner it
works when you've got about the right
amount of speed for the corner but it's
super useful to break the rear tires
free when they don't really want to
crashing a car transporter to
[Music]
so what you're looking at here is a
couple of cop cars that crash into each
other a little bit behind the scenes
into some of what the stunt guys are
doing here you can see underneath the
vertical car where there's a few sort of
metal rails that have been added on
where the one car is gonna impact the
bottom of it and then as that vehicle
makes contact and breaks through that
first car you can see there's nobody in
that second cruiser at all
so a car like this that you're gonna do
some stunt driving with you're gonna
want to make some safety modifications
to the addition of a racing seat and
real five-point seatbelts a racing
harness is gonna make that a lot safer
not bad to mother ever teach you to say
thank you one additional thing that they
probably fitted most of these cars is a
dry cell battery a normal car battery in
a collision the problem is that it's
acid filled and that's nothing you want
any of your people dealing with it's
just not good so a regular dry cell
battery like we would use a racecar is
much safer and you can mount that in a
safe location so that the more impact
you take that battery in that fuel cell
are still gonna be safe high-speed
driving in Reverse Drive
what you've got here is a five liter
Mustang GT in a race with a Chrysler 300
which even if that is the souped-up
version the Mustang is gonna just walk
away from it any day so we're kind of
departing from reality from the
beginning
it's good stunt-driving it was
well-executed once he does his forward
180 which is probably just because it's
on the kind of stunt-driving menu to
pick from you can only go about as fast
and reverse as you can in first year so
now the other guys got a massive
advantage and why didn't they say
anything there's just no reason to ever
tactically do that especially when your
car can easily outrun the other one time
travel back to the future
again you really have to look at you
know an air-cooled Volkswagen bus
keeping up with a de Lorean DeLoreans
were slow I'll give you that but they're
not that slow an air-cooled little
Volkswagen you would just drive away
from it and the story would be over see
if you can do 90 as far as getting up
enough speed to travel through time when
this baby hits 88 miles per hour
they're gonna see some serious 88 miles
an hour and all DeLorean with all of
that stuff bolted in the back it could
be a challenge you know in just a mall
parking lot the answers tape you would
ideally want a much longer stretch of
road but conceivably sure he could get
up to 88 and jump through time off-road
driving die hard with a vengeance super
fun scene to watch some high speed
off-road driving in a taxicab the one
kind of shout out that I'd have for that
is the seatbelt thing how about we just
skip down the deployer you tell me what
this has to do with me
maintaining good control of that vehicle
and you're gonna be bouncing your head
on the seal and your feet are coming off
the pedals it's gonna be really ugly
oh yeah asking me at element you gotta
get your seatbelt on
there's a couple of big jumps
one in the park and one leaving the park
getting back onto the pavement the main
fear there is obviously you know broken
suspension but really your oil pan
crashing down on the road and get the
hole in your oil pan and destroying the
engine but you can see towards the end
of this where there's actually a skid
plate that they've added underneath the
oil pan of the car to handle that last
jump more SUVs an off-road oriented
pickup trucks are gonna have some of
that but in a normal sedan it's gonna be
a little bit up to you to take that
initiative and do some of that rugged
izing on your own driving off a cliff
Thelma and Louise
[Music]
all right so yeah nobody definitely
would have survived what I like there
though is that she did sort of preload
the suspension with a little left foot
brake and accelerate are you talking
about
one of the main reasons for left foot
braking is to control the movement of
the suspension if you were about to go
off a jump for instance it might make
sense to add a little left foot brake
and that will compress those front
Springs and then right before you go off
of that jump release the brake full
throttle and that spring is gonna unload
and take the weight off of the front
just like you went on a bicycle or a
skateboard or anything else so it's
really good driving it's great she's
left foot braking but uh yeah nobody's
gonna survive that one my god driving on
two wheels
the fate of the Furious
so this is a really good stunt performed
perfectly it's all real there's nothing
sort of CG about it if you find yourself
up on two wheels do what you need to do
is turn whichever way at that point is
downhill we'll put the car back down
onto four wheels and if you turn uphill
it would get you closer to and/or
rolling over once you get used to that
balance point what you're gonna need is
one a lot of air pressure in your tires
and two you need a locking differential
a locking differential is going to set
equal power to both driven wheels
regardless of whether one's on ice and
the others on pavement or ones in the
air when you accelerate it'll still put
power down even if your vehicle is only
on two wheels
precision parking ace venture when
nature calls
not at all obviously possible or
advisable under any circumstance how do
they do it in the movie though you can
tell that initial rollover is caused by
some kind of a charge you can see the
land rover is driving along fine and
then literally there's an explosion and
underneath it almost that causes that
vehicle to start tumbling in a big
rollover and then later on when they go
into their parking spot that vehicles
literally just getting dropped from the
crane for that really quick little 1
second shot you might want to think
about getting this baby detail
flipping a truck the dark night
[Music]
doesn't go to the odd set and watch that
go down that's a real stunt that's a
real truck doing a real flip would it
happen like that in the real world
absolutely not
bull if you did somehow managed to stop
the cab of an 18-wheeler they're really
two very separate parts that are only
connected by a trailer hitch essentially
so it wouldn't all happen in one big
piece like that you ought to know you
bought it to do this stunt
they created a really lightweight
version of a tractor-trailer truck that
was all one piece and mounted a huge
nitrogen cannon in the back of it you
can see that huge gas discharge again
when the truck flips over but again it's
not CG it's all real it's especially
made rigged to do that one stunt but
it's super cool canyon arrow The
Simpsons wow this is roomy
can you name the truck with pool wheel
drive smells like a steak and seats 35
can you narrow narrow spectacular
so the canyon arrow is kind of The
Simpsons stab at the Americans love for
large sport utility vehicles top of the
line and utility sports unexplained
fires are a matter for the court it
climbs up a mountain of cars a
metaphorical I'm sure physically to
climb up a mountain of cars wouldn't
happen the Federal Highway Commission
has ruled the canyon arrow unsafe for
highway or city driving driving through
buildings bad boys too
we see this a lot in a lot of different
car chases and kind of action scenes
cars driving through buildings this is
the more dramatic one just because
they're drug dealers shacks that explode
when you hit them all right so no
vehicle is actually ever gonna take this
amount of abuse driving the Hummer h2
kind of our Canyon arrow and real life
here is made by GM it's kind of an
amalgamation what the hell is that
supposed to mean essentially it's a
Chevy truck with a body on it this scene
it's super fun to watch there's
explosions there's you know jumping cars
many times over and crashing through
buildings and all of this stuff but when
it gets to the bottom and everybody
drives away and the things still in one
piece not gonna happen
overcompensating tough guy jumping
between two buildings Furious 7
as much fun as it is I think we all know
on this one that yeah it's not anything
that a normal car would ever handle oh
boy what
[Music]
so in the second building when is breaks
around you can't get the brakes to work
easiest thing to do is most of the time
shut the engine off or you can just do
what they did in the third building
which is get the car into a big skid get
it sideways to the road and use that to
get the vehicle slowed down and
hopefully to a stop flipping a car
Casino Royale
all right so credit where credit's do
that's all a real car it's all a real
stunt and it was probably terrifying for
whoever was in there they tried to roll
the car with a standard kind of a ramp
and they couldn't get it to roll it's so
wide and it's so low
what happens here is the cars driving
along they deploy this gas cannon which
flips the vehicle very quickly and this
one actually set a record for the most
times they've rolled a car side over
side like that in the movies seven times
total it could clean stunts pretty scary
stuff the big bus jump from speed
[Music]
it's of course fake you would need a
ramp of some kind just like you would on
a bicycle or a skateboard or anything
else to jump across a gap like that if
you do need to go off a jump with a car
you definitely want to get your speed
sort of checked where you need to be and
then be on the gas aggressively through
that transition and off of that jump so
that the car planes out reasonably well
in the air jumping a car onto the
highway Duke's a hazard
[Applause]
so again respect for using a real card
not going the CG route I'm always ready
to go that far really cool but yeah
everyone would have died
headed neck trauma back stuff silly
things if you land a car that hard
you're not gonna walk away from it so
the most common way that you see these
cars launched is just simply through the
use of ramps and often again nitrogen
charged Skoda gas cannons can provide a
huge amount of acceleration thrust but
yeah that's a real complete car that
they somehow sent off a ramp and it what
huge exhaust flames too fast too furious
in a normal modern car you're not gonna
see a lot of exhaust flames at all the
problem is you would need a lot of
unburnt air & fuel mixture going out of
your exhaust pipe to create those flames
and maybe people are doing that out
there on the street to try and be cool
but it's not something that's happening
as a side benefit of making a lot of
horsepower at all
oil slick Nightrider so what you've got
here is a pretty typical kind of spy
gadget the old oil slick behind you it's
been the guy out if you really did have
some kind of an oil slick you'd want it
to spread out and fan out a little
better so if you do realize for some
reason that the road ahead is really
slippery be really smooth and light with
any steering that you do and any
throttle or brake that you try and apply
while you're on that slippery surface
brake nice and easy steer nice and easy
otherwise you're gonna be spinning out
and crashing into stuff all over the
place talking while driving strange brew
hey did you ever notice that like in
movies that they when they're driving
like they don't look at the road like
for a long time keep going I never
noticed that really cool to see them
call this out and it's something that's
super common and we've all seen driving
along and you're just having a big chat
and not really paying attention yeah
that's because they're being told
really by like a rig
[Music]
it's cuz that car is probably on a
flatbed trailer they're just driving
along getting towed by someone having a
conversation conclusion it's really cool
in this day and age to see so many
filmmakers using real cars with real
drivers doing real stunts going pretty
big and doing some scary stuff and it
looks like a lot of fun it could be so
easy to do it all with computers and you
know thank you so much everybody who's
making these films for all of your hard
work and we really do appreciate it
and that's a wrap
[Applause]
[Music]